doce días en río para conseguir el
preciado suero contra el hobbit 19 desde
sus aldeas en la profundidad de la selva
amazónica brasileña fronteriza con
colombia y perú más de 35 miembros de la
remota comunidad indígena matisse
dejaron sus malocas subidas en una
barcaza de madera viajaron hasta atalaya
do norte el pueblo más cercano para
recibir la segunda dosis de la vacuna
parent
de nueva ciudad mi pariente viene de la
aldea pixie misma algunos tienen para
vacunarse otros vienen para arreglar la
documentación de sus hijos documentos
que necesitan para la bolsa de familia
maternidad todo eso por su familia
los equipos de vacunación no han podido
acceder a sus remotas aldeas en las
pasadas campañas de inoculación muchos
hombres de la comunidad se encontraban
cazando pescando por lo que no
recibieron las dosis ante el miedo a
contraer la enfermedad que deja más de
mil indígenas muertos por el virus en
brasil decidieron tomar la iniciativa y
salir al exterior en busca de la vacuna
llevando consigo sus artesanías locales
para costearse el viaje de vuelta a la
selva
no sabemos qué está pasando afuera pero
así nosotros conseguimos gasolina para
poder retornar a la aldea nosotros no
dependemos de la funai ni de la sesa y
nosotros vamos rebuscando vamos
consiguiendo dinero de a poquito así
vamos consiguiendo solventar para
regresar a la aldea eso hacemos
si bien la remota comunidad matiz no ha
registrado ningún caso de kobe 19 entre
sus miembros a finales de 1976 cuando
fueron contactados por el exterior por
primera vez el 3 por ciento de la
población matiz murió a causa de varias
epidemias como la malaria o la gripe
ahora la muerte de sus chamanes o la
pérdida de tierras amenaza con diezmar
su comunidad